I was diagnosed with terminal brain
cancer my senior year of college and
given six months to live it's just
proven the model that if you give
someone what they didn't know they
needed that sounds like them that feels
like them that has that level of
absolute empathy that they're seeking
that isn't there in the Health Care
system
you can measure how much that helps them
make better decisions you're hired okay
hey great
and there he is Matthew's a new friend
uh he's got a company called Off Script
health and the way that I would describe
and you can let me know if I'm way off
base is a podcast network of experts
coming on sharing their Journey around
the various health things that they've
been through with the goal to empower
and inspire people struggling with
similar issues to Take Back Control of
their own health
how does that sound you're hired okay
hey great
script and there's no T at the end so o
f f s c r i p Health yeah and there's a
whole bunch of shows on there so you
started it I mean your background's in
in the uh content creation game talking
about you know the journey through
cancer everything else
what is the mission or the bigger
picture behind Off Script
well um I was diagnosed with terminal
brain cancer my senior year of college
and given six months to live uh that was
27 years ago so I'm glad they were wrong
lots of people are glad they were wrong
so I was going to draft it into this
space against my will
and I I didn't really know what to do
this was the 90s when everything was a
whole lot worse
but I fell back on a career in media I
worked at Omnicom and people know The
Agency Group for 10 years and then I
fell into the uh the politics of
healthcare Beltway in DC for a long time
I started the non-profit called stupid
cancer if anyone's watching or listening
that knows anybody with cancer in their
20s and 30s stupid cancer is the
National Organization for young adult
cancer
um and I had a radio show during that
time before the internet live talk radio
show
and it dawned on me that when Healthcare
lands on anyone I mean Americans in my
particular case
you're kind of left in a Charlie Brown
teacher landscape where there's nothing
but Google your doctor and chaos
and as a non-profit leader
the only thing you want to do is be
there for that person when they didn't
know they needed you
and that was always the issue I've been
frustrated with is that everyone tries
to be there the second year diagnosed
the second happens and that's not really
possible
but this answer of social media and
videos and the information age
um I just feel like it's a little too
noisy now and it's the opposite of a
vacuum camera it was the 1990s so I love
stupid cancer four years ago and I
really wanted to build a company
centered on
letting patients know they're not alone
through podcasting by creating this
niche market of smaller podcasts now we
tend to think a podcast as maximum reach
and hitting everybody you know but
you know a show about multiple sclerosis
doesn't need to hit every American it
needs to hit the right Americans the
right listeners that was the business
model behind this company is like I call
it anti-media it's media you don't hope
to have to listen to ever I can't wait
to get cancer and listen to my show
right that's not a thing people say so
how do you think about content creation
when there's no demand for it it's a
very different way to think about it
because they're not expecting it to be
there you can serve it to them so by
finding the key I would almost say the
key talents in podcasting across nearly
every different disease vertical whether
it's cancer rare disease multiple
sclerosis Sickle Cell uh endometriosis
and building this community of
communities who have a power of voice
that was the idea behind this company
and we've been very successful we've
reached almost three million people in
three and in two years coming up with
three years really soon but it's just
proven the model that if you give
someone what they didn't know they
needed
that sounds like them that feels like
them that has that level of absolute
empathy that they're seeking that isn't
there in the Health Care system
you can measure how much that helps them
make better decisions so is the vision
to have a thousand different shows on
all these micro niches around different
Health themes the scalable strategy is
yes to create this Surat like pointless
painting of numerous different shows
hosted by leaders who have existing
communities and amplifying all of our
voices at once through the shared
economy I love it and how are people so
I'm more familiar with like YouTube
World visual world and distributions
kind of baked into the model right so we
we did a video on
dyslexia and how it could be an
advantage for you or ADHD and how it can
be an advantage for you so instead of
seeing it as it was a series called No
Limits where most people see these
things as a negative it's like okay here
are people who've had tremendous success
with the ADHD or dyslexia
um we haven't done anything on cancer
but people
are searching on YouTube and they'll
find the video and then they watch it
and they may not be searching for that
specific like hope they get an
inspirational video but because they're
searching for dyslexia or ADHD they end
up finding the video so the distribution
is already built in because people are
on YouTube Looking For Education how do
you get the distribution and people
finding all of these Micro Niche shows
well that's a great question it kind of
goes to the idea of you know we're not
based on ad units everything we do is
pre-underwritten by corporate partners
and Healthcare Communications
organizations and Pharma biotech
Walgreens things like that because we
know who's listening in advance
so people don't have to search for our
stuff because we push it to them through
programmatic and social advertising it's
a very DTC way to think about serving
content to people who would never think
to look at it or listen to I mean I was
going to say let's take that again with
this live just my radio roots are
showing up here it was great we're
trying to serve content to people not
looking for it or who don't know they
could even start to look for it and also
the content we're putting together it's
not Medical
like yours isn't medical it's life hacks
it's how did you deal with your kids how
did you pay your bills but it's also
awareness of clinical treatments we
don't mention any particular Brands like
a drug commercial and television but
I'll give you one example and this is
good for your listeners to understand
your viewers sorry your viewers I'm
scared biscuits okay
um I'll put it this way
um your genetics your DNA how you're
made up like the randomness that you are
is a biological piece of meat determines
whether you live or die too often when
bad things happen to you it doesn't
matter if it's cancer or not so certain
treatments don't work for certain people
but you don't know about the treatments
that do so there's a lot of information
in that Charlie Brown teacher moment
with anybody whether it's a
life-threatening disease or chronic
condition where you just don't know to
even ask the fundamental questions of
can I get a genetic test for
endometriosis or Sickle Cell you don't
think to ask these questions so it goes
a little deeper into the mechanics of
this that you're swimming in a level
perhaps below the I'm part of something
I love that I can hear other people see
other people that sound like me
but in the trenches of reimbursements
and jargony stuff like formulary
exemptions and uh Hospital billing
situations it's all these minutiae life
hacks are are the real stressors of
millions of Americans every single day
and that's the role that our talent
plays and that's the role that our
content serves so if you look at
something like Endo
um are you going to have a show that a
doctor host that somebody's going
through it you know is hosting a family
member of like the husband of somebody
who's gone through it does it matter
like how do you pick who's the host of
these shows well we acquire existing
shows that have sustainable growing
audiences and consider us um an
incubator accelerator of those shows we
did acquire my friend Melissa Woodrow's
show called the cycle
which is the number two endometriosis
podcast in the country and we've doubled
her listenership we're getting sponsors
to increase How We Do paid search and
paid push
um and then we acquired the number one
multiple sclerosis show in the country
hosted by a patient I think that's an
important thing to mention we don't want
to get into the jargon of medicine we
don't want to talk about the
um sort of the academic voices of
medicine we are the people we're serving
we are the customers of our podcast so
having a talented host that knows how to
have a conversation that is commanding
in her leadership as a patient advocate
is very very strong and that is the
secret sauce because you want to hear
somebody that sounds like you and I
think the psychology of radio is you
want to shake your head and Nod because
they're saying all the things that are
inside your head
are you trying to build an off-script
brand where like if it's Off Script
approved
it adds to the I don't want to say
legitimacy but maybe to The Prestige
like a Michelin comes in and rates a
restaurant it's still a good restaurant
right like it's a great restaurant but
now it's Michelin approved now it's even
better perceived like are you trying to
build that with Off Script or are you
trying to be more behind the scenes like
we built this network but we're not
trying to build a brand ourselves I
think it's too easy to start a podcast
and not know what you're doing I mean I
know we're talking over the air here but
you know we have professional hardware
and also you have that too we want to
become Best in Class audio production
this isn't to dismiss other people that
have fabulous shows and have wonderful
audiences but there's no like NPR level
standard of Storytelling and content
because we want to professionalize the
patient voice over audio and media so
our standard is not like a stamp of
approval you're Good Housekeeping you're
part of our network but yeah there's an
unlimited supply of talent that we want
to punch up as comedians say to our
Network and improve the quality of the
audio the production value the guest
selections make it easy for them to be
who they are and nothing more because
that's all they should really be
focusing on
and so is that actively part of whether
your con time every day or somebody in
the team is like Hey we're looking to
one go spot talent and then to
potentially buy them out or or partner
with them and maybe it's not a full bio
and then three like upgrade their skills
because they may have just started a
podcast on their own in their closet and
they're just going they've never had any
coaching training because an endo
podcast like who do you go to to learn
this stuff so is that an active part of
your schedule or somebody on the team
like that's basically what you're doing
every day yeah we well I mean we do lots
of things every day we have a team of 26
people right now but yeah uh we have a
list of like 50 to 70 podcasts that
exist right now we do have some Metric
they have to be around for a while they
have to have us a basic growing
listenership that we can measure metrics
around they have to have some level of
personal brand associated with what they
do and they have to just be a good
interviewer so we have some basic
criteria that we you need to start with
to identify existing shows and bring
them into the network strategically to
make sure that that together our voices
our latter strategy works but there's a
wonderful cross-pollination I love the
phrase that it's not about what you have
it's about what you have in common
parents in the Sickle Cell space can
learn from parents in the breast cancer
space you know you know children in the
uh in the um the uh um there's my brain
not working 27 years later in the uh
epilepsy space you can learn from
children in the narcolepsy space there's
a Common Thread across all disease
markets where what you have is really
important and that's where treatments
come in and your doctor comes in but
we're all just trying to live our lives
and do the best that we can with the
crap that's dealt with us and that is
the power of community
wrapped in a community
so is it just on the surface I looked at
it and you're going after these micro
niches and it feels like there's not a
lot of cross-pollination like if I have
epilepsy what do I care about the
narcolepsy show or Endo show I mean I
guess sure there's a level of of
um
trauma and just community and
self-belief and like mindset stuff but
do I get enough of like would I listen
to a entire show dedicated to Endo if I
don't have it it feels to me like no but
I'm I'm curious what the
cross-pollinations are whether it's just
the fact that the creators are
supporting each other whether you're
creating the Off Script Health Summit
for people to come to in your own shows
like where is the cross-pollination for
the communities there when the subject
matter may not be as relevant to people
well a lot of the information on these
shows is fairly Evergreen and they're
applicable across a life cycle and you
think about like a mom raising a
teenager with narcolepsy or a mom
raising a teenager with epilepsy those
two moms have so many things in common
in terms of how do you get them to
school how do you get their their
prescriptions refilled how do you
explain to teachers what's wrong with
your child how do you tell someone
they're not just tired they have
narcolepsy how do you build these
stigmatizations when they're getting
bullied at school so these are really
common threads and just one example of
what we have to deal with irrespective
of what's wrong with us or our kids so
how do you do you just have like a giant
email list for people then kind of opt
into different themes like if if if
somebody's hosting the Endo show and the
guest is going to be a mom talking about
what it's like to be a mom with Endo
then and or your kids have whatever have
ended up cool that might be interesting
to all the other moms who are out there
but if the core audience isn't moms like
how do you push that show about is it
just through advertising that you're
saying hey if you're a mom you should
watch the show well we're just getting
into phase two which is cross-pollinated
in the content across all the shows and
building that newsletter structure where
everything goes out and you see what's
in the feed or we're thinking about the
ring reverse idea where everything is on
one feed and it's just a separate thing
that everyone can join in and dive into
and learn from but yeah the common
threads at least to me personally are
the single most important thing about
what we can share based on our
experiences and again like what we have
is one thing but our common threads are
another thing so yes we just did a show
on one of our Dr Mitzi crock of our host
a show on our Network go beyond the
paper ground and she's a luminary
Women's Health Physician and they
obviously were in a space a state of
this country around uh fertility rights
and Reproductive Rights and she did a
whole show about this issue when we
shared that show on every other show on
the network to demonstrate to all of our
listeners yeah well more than just this
show we're a network of amazing things
you can discover and you go through a
podcast feed oh my God this show is all
about uh how to deal with my mom when
she when she's she needs Medicare
Assistance or whatever
yeah I mean it by the names of the shows
it feels easy to opt in based off of the
disease that you're dealing with or the
health issue that you're dealing with
the topics inside it I wonder if if
there were an easy way to opt in like if
I I have a 13 year old son if I was
worried about him being bullied in
school and there was a show on the
on the narcolepsy Channel about bullying
like maybe I watched it even though I
don't care at all about so if I could
opt in to say hey anything bullying I
want to know about I don't know how many
themes kind of you would go across but
then if that it just becomes as
impossible 8 000 theme checklist of
things people opt into but it seems to
me that that would be a pretty powerful
way to maybe I never subscribed to the
narcolepsy podcast but if I know that
there's episodes on bullying and that's
what I care about then maybe the expert
coming on can actually give me some
advice that I'll listen to right I mean
we're not like Crisis radio in that
sense but we're think about the common
things we deal with every day you know
um uh fertility dating Insurance careers
um just general fear and anxiety quite
being a human being let alone
indecisions and decisions with the
medical community your insurance
changing out of nowhere your drugs not
getting covered all those things are
common across the core of our content so
yeah I mean you might not care about
narcolepsy which is a good problem to
have that hasn't landed on you but yeah
there are plenty of parents coming on
all of our shows explaining how they get
by raising a six-year-old they're
dealing with dear old dad who's got
who's not compliant on his app to
measure his cardiovascular those are the
things that we find most valuable and
yeah phase two which we're moving into
right now is how do we collect all the
data of the content and make it
available to anyone based on what they
need not what they have
yeah I love it whether it's show notes
that I can just search I don't know I'm
thinking out loud I'm sure you have all
the plans already but like my wheels
eternally this is a genius idea uh now I
already said you were hired so great I'm
an official spokesperson I nailed the
intro
uh I I mean I I'm the video guy I love
YouTube
is is video a part of the plan going
forward or like this is only going to be
an audio Network
I was looking at it from a
non-competitive but relevance
perspective there's a certain psychology
in the radio that you just can't
duplicate anywhere else and I don't
think this is as generational as I
originally thought it was growing up
with only radio on black and white
television totally dating myself and
we're in a different place right now but
it's part of an omni-channel psychology
video is great for here television is
great for here streaming Netflix is
great for there but there's nothing like
the Simplicity of using only one sensory
organ to listen quietly in your car on a
bus while you're commuting somewhere in
the kitchen it's different you don't
have to sit down and stare at something
and watch it and then synthesize it it's
all going into your brain and your ears
right away and if if it's something that
emotionally connects with you when you
fill out all your other senses the one
remaining is the most profound
so radio audio is is so powerful when
used the right way and complement and
augment to other forms of content media
yeah I mean I ask because I've helped a
lot of people in the podcasting move to
YouTube and a lot of shows now are
picking up huge audiences on video like
if you're recording the audio and anyway
you're you're booking the guests and
doing the sessions and doing all the
planning and doing it like why not put
some cameras in there and and the video
quality doesn't even have to be as long
as you can hear it like the audio is
super important if you can yeah even if
it's a video and you can't hear it
nobody's going to watch it right but you
don't have to be Mr Beast to win because
it's it's education and especially like
the content you're making probably
doesn't exist anywhere else and the
opportunity to potentially Reach people
who are struggling with this thing and
meeting them where they're at like some
people will default to go to an audio
only experience a lot of people default
to a YouTube like YouTube's become the
search engine where people are typing in
how do I deal with
endo and like your show could come up
and it's probably better than anything
that already exists on the platform even
if it's just like a simple webcam on the
person filming because it's about
quality of thought not as much video
production quality no I agree with
everything you're saying I think what we
wanted to do is is do the proof of
concept that there is no
there is no content exclusively for
consumer health
doesn't exist right now so mentally
viable we work with a medium that is
high marginal volume that's fairly
straightforward how to create the best
standards of audio production across all
of our hosting content and if we see an
update which we have it makes sense to
consider the value of throwing cameras
in all the rooms now and building it on
the channel strategy around what we're
producing but we just had to make sure
people would be willing to listen to
things first because like I said it's
anti-media no one's looking for it in
that sense they might be looking for it
on YouTube or Google and you're right
they don't list podcast results in
Google or YouTube I'd like to see
someone invent that maybe we could do
that together there's a billion dollar
idea let's go search on Google for
podcasts exactly but and then they'll
probably list their own Google podcasts
anyway so you'd lose out all the others
irrespective we wanted to demonstrate
that the success of a stupid cancer show
which I hosted for 13 years which had
almost 4 million downloads over 500
episodes
was this Beacon of opportunity to
commercialize and bring to more people
across the country because all those
people needed in that moment was to
listen
and now we've proven yet again that
American Health consumers who have
health care landing on them and
destroying their lives enjoy an
opportunity to listen and then watch and
then go do
so there's no reason why we can't scale
to meet the new expectations of search
but it was absolutely critical to
demonstrate the proof of concept that
they're interested in listening yeah I
mean the thing with I mean you've proven
that and you're also only hiring you're
only buying shows that already exist and
have already taken off and already have
listenership and you feel like hey if we
gave some new gear to the host or we
helped train them up like we can help
double the listenership right so you're
not as much like hey we should start
this brand new thing from scratch we're
working with already established people
um but we do produce original content we
produce our own original content we did
a documentary last year which I'd love
to talk about the cancer Mavericks it
was a history series an eight-part uh
eight-part narrative series Think Like
This American Life for cancer advocacy
but it started in the 1960s it goes to
the decades about how we are all living
today with the system we have for For
Better or For Worse because of Heroes we
never heard of before
like think of Ken burn PBS documentary
but for the people and it's been
listening to a half a million times the
cancer Mavericks wherever you listen to
podcasts we brought that to Market so
we're documentarians at the same time
and we have a a pipeline of five more
documentaries we're working on for the
next three years so that's part of our
original content strategy and we also do
mini series like limited three-part
series exclusively for small disease
markets and these are markets that have
no non-profits no communities and
there's nothing on search I'm talking
rare disease communities where there's
50 of them and they have nothing and
that's a wonderful Niche to serve
and those are audio all Audio Only too
all audio and anyone listening and
watching could go to offscript no T
because I'm annoying.com and check out
our library for 27 shows and series
because you know I'm all for the whole
country knowing all these wonderful
things but we wanted to start backwards
and look at who needs information the
most because there isn't a search term
for what they have
and who needs information from people
that look and sound like them first
because that's what you don't you don't
get that when you're diagnosed and
thrown to the Gristmill
so how do you when you're I mean I get
when you're building up a podcast you
get a loyal listenership people they
wait for the next episode whether it's
weekly or bi-weekly or whatever when
you're doing a mini series or a one-off
documentary
how do you get the word out about it
well cancer Mavericks we did no
marketing for it it was entirely
Grassroots and we're a year and three
months since it launched and we're still
getting updates and people are
downloading it I mean it made its way
through the the pedagogical World it
made it way to the the nursing and
Doctor accreditation World it made its
way through all the non-profits we were
worked with 175 non-profits across the
country because those are my
relationships I built over the last 25
years
so it again it just reinforces the idea
that it's not a people that will come
but it's a history series it's education
it teaches people
how messed up things are today but how
much worse they used to be if it weren't
for like 14 people you never heard of
with regard to like the Sickle Cell
series
you know that's Evergreen we can
endlessly promote that
out the Wazoo with great campaigns to
the communities that need it most to the
podcasters in the Sickle Cell community
and through standard direct and consumer
advertising and especially through the
medical community because doctors want
to give patients hope that's beyond the
medicine and who better to tell them
have a listen to this it's all about you
built for You Made For You by people
like you
I love it man you know usually when I
have people on we're talking about
social media hashtag search engine
showing up and suggested how do I rank
in YouTube and you've built it like the
complete opposite way of Grassroots and
media and paid media and networking and
P like it's great it's amazing to see
the success that um that you've had and
I love
I love everything you're building for
people who want to find you uh he
doesn't do Instagram live this first one
so we made we made this happen which is
great but if they want to find out about
you the show the network like what's the
best next spot for them well very
simplicitly my name is Matthew Zachary
and if you Google me on the first 14
Google search Pages I've earned that
I've scraped nothing it's all real it's
me the 15th is some other guy named
Matthew Zachary who writes books that's
not me but my show is called adaptations
patience obviously spelled the way it's
supposed to be because we all are out of
patience I welcome CEOs of organizations
across the country I welcome luminaries
building the latest genomic medications
you're never going to get because the FD
you want to prove them I rally millions
of people to basically uh do right
things at the legislative level to
demand like your hospital can't bill you
your fertility is covered by your
employer
um you're entitled as a psychosocial
mental health benefits When cancer
happens your hospital should be doing a
b and c these standards should exist
when doctors tell you you have cancer or
rare diseases I live in the sub-basement
of health care right if you do it right
no one knows and that's kind of how I
live my life this is good exposure for
me but I've been doing this for 20 years
and I don't need 300 million people to
know who I am and the other people
behind me there are thousands of us but
it's important for everyone listening
every American again because that's our
Market to understand that there are
really incredibly
I don't know sneaky ways to track if I
can be so exploitative because I'm
really angry all the time uh with
insurance little things like that that
we just don't know we can do your drugs
are cheaper across the street you don't
have to pay your hospital bills all the
time there are these this is what
bothers me all day so this is what I
talk about on my show we have the top
Endo show on Ms show Women's Health show
we have um a business executive femtech
VC show
we have all sorts of documentaries that
are out there
um yeah that was a very long answer to
your question Matthew's actually my
Show's application
we just invite everyone to learn again
we hope you don't need the content we're
putting out there but if you do we're
glad you're here
well I love the passion dude I love the
energy I love everything you poured into
it uh if you ever want to go video happy
to be a part and help I know who I know
a guy I
yeah exactly appreciate you man thank
you for coming on and and best of luck
and build this into a giant Empire that
changes the world thank you Evan take
care appreciate you bye do you see my
one-on-one with Matthew McConaughey
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there sometimes it's
not about what decision you make just
make one and commit to it
self-determination and faith
intentionality and trust I mean it's
always a balance of those two and that's
what keeps life being a consistent game